und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
fasst man die Erkenntnisse dieses Tages
zusammen so hat Vladimir Putin heute
drei Dinge getan 1 er hat offenbart
unter welchem Druck er steht sonst hätte
er diese mobilenmachung nicht nötig
zweitens er hat getan was er
ursprünglich vermeiden wollte nämlich
das russische Volk mit den
Unannehmlichkeiten eines Krieges zu
konfrontieren bislang konnte man im
russischen Kernland zu tun als gäbe es
den nur im Fernsehen und alles laufe
großartig drittens er hat der Ukraine
und ihrem Unterstützern gedroht wieder
einmal in einer Tonlage die an Mafia
Filme erinnert Zitat ich blöffe nicht
doch schon diese kraftvolle Ankündigung
kam mit Verzögerung berichtet Andreas
Kühnast
für Tag 209 des Krieges für Punkt 20 Uhr
Moskauer Zeit hat der Kreml eine
besondere Bekanntmachung des Präsidenten
angekündigt aber es läuft nicht nach
Plan kein Putin keine Bekanntmachung
keine Begründung der Abend vergeht die
Nacht 13 rätselhafte Stunden vergehen
bis Putin auftauchen wird bis er bekannt
geben wird alles laufe nach Plan hat er
bereits das Gegenteil bewiesen
es ist sagt Putin am Morgen um 9 Uhr
unser Schicksal jene zu stoppen die nach
Weltherrschaft streben die unser
Vaterland zerstückeln wollen und
unterjochen unser Schicksal auch diesmal
ich glaube an Ihre Unterstützung
kein Krieg kein Krieg an ihre
Unterstützung wird Putin nicht geglaubt
haben zum ersten Mal seit Monaten wieder
trauen sich Russlands Kriegsgegner in
allen größeren Städten auf die Straßen
wunderschön unsere Leute dürfen nicht
sterben unsere Mütter haben schon dann
führt man ihn ab Russlands Regierung
geht mit der Teilmobilmachung das Risiko
ein dass der einkalkulierte Protest zu
einer Protestwelle wird es verrät so
deutlich wie nie es läuft nicht nach
Plan es verrät eigentlich das Putin
jetzt nicht mehr agiert sondern reagiert
er muss reagieren auf die militärische
Niederlage und den ukrainischen Druck
und jetzt versucht er sozusagen wieder
in die Offensive zu kommen im russischen
Internet heute unübersehbar die eine
Reaktion auf die bevorstehenden
Einberufungen von Reservisten ab 18
Jahren Spott
in russischen Zeitungen die andere Angst
Direktflüge in die Nachbarstaaten heute
und morgen ausgebucht danach bis zu
zehnmal teurer als vor Putins Rede
bist du wir ziehen 300.000 treservisten
ein und ich sage gleich das wird keine
einmalige Aktion
die ganze Welt hat jetzt fragen und
schreit sie am Sitz der UNO den
weltlenkern zu
[Musik]
der Westen antwortet Putin
wir stehen in Solidarität mit der
Ukraine in Solidarität gegen die
russische Aggression Punkt
auch Außenministerin baerbock und
Kanzler Scholz sind in New York als
Putin die eskalationsrede hält als
Russland ankündigt in den besetzten
Gebieten sogenannte Abstimmungen
durchzuführen um sie anschließend genau
wie die Krim in seinen Staatsgebiet
einzufleiben das wird niemals akzeptiert
werden können in der Welt in der wir
leben muss das Recht über die Gewalt
Siegen und kann nicht die Gewalt stärker
sein als das Recht für Putin werden auch
die neuanektierten Gebiete Russland sein
er droht dem Westen mit stärkster Gewalt
bei einer Gefährdung der territorialen
Integrität Russlands werden wir
unbedingt alle Mittel einsetzen die uns
zur Verfügung stehen dies ist kein blöff
wenn man selber sagen muss das ist kein
blöd dann spricht vieles dafür dass er
sich um einen Block handelt sonst müsste
man das nicht so betonen ob Russland
läuft ob es droht ob es mobil macht
russland zeigt es läuft nicht nach Plan
und von den Vereinten Nationen in New
York ist uns der Nato-Generalsekretär
Jens Stoltenberg zugeschaltet guten
Namen ist das dortenberg wo die winning
guten Abend eine der bemerkenswerten
Passagen heute von Wladimir Putin war wo
er indirekt mit nuklearschlägen droht
und dann hinzufügte dies sei kein Bluff
wie werden sie das ist das ein Bluff
das ist eine
nukleare Rhetorik von präsent Putin das
ist gefährlich das ist
leichtsinnig und Präsident Putin muss
wissen dass ein
nuklear Krieg
niemals
gekämpft werden sollte und kann auch
nicht gewonnen werden das ist etwas was
er selber auch weiß
und wir werden natürlich sehr nah die
Situation beobachten was er tut wir
haben soweit keine Veränderungen in der
nuklearen Bereitschaft Russlands gesehen
was er selbst aber verändert hat ist
quasi die russische nuklear Doktrin
quasi im Vorbeigehen heute die bezog
sich bisher darauf zu sagen Russland
greift zu Nuklearwaffen wenn es selbst
existenziell angegriffen wird oder wenn
es mit Nuklearwaffen angegriffen wird
heute sagte er nun und fügte dann zu
auch im Falle einer Bedrohung der
territorialen Integrität unseres Landes
würde man zu Art von Waffen greifen
hängt das nicht mit diesen Referenten
zusammen die er jetzt auch gerade
abhalten lässt
und dies ist
aber nicht das erste Mal dass wir da
verschiedene nukleare Drohungen hören
aus Russland Leiter das ist leider schon
mehrfach passiert auf unterschiedliche
Weisen und das verändert aber nichts was
unseren Pflicht bedeutet ruhig zu
bleiben und klar zu seinen Russland kann
keine nuklearen Krieg gewinnen und der
darf auch gar nicht ausgefochten werden
und das führte ja die Natur dieses
Konfliktes verändern mit
unvorhergesehenen Konsequenzen und das
haben wir auch ganz klar Russland
gegenüber kommuniziert
weiß die NATO also wie Sie darauf
reagieren würde und weiß Putin auch wie
die NATO dann reagieren würde
responedieren wir werden aber es ist
ganz klar dass es da das Konsequenzen
gäbe wenn du klärwaffen eingesetzt wird
dann eine
nuklearkonflikt ist gefährlich für
Russland und auch für den Rest der Welt
und das ist der Grund warum es so
wichtig ist zu verhindern dass das
passiert die Nato will keine
Konfrontation mit Russland wir sind alle
verteidigungsorganisation wir sind nicht
Teil dieses Konfliktes und das gilt auch
für die Verbündeten der NATO wie
Deutschland wir sind nicht in der
Ukraine am Boden und
die NATO Verbündeten haben die Ukraine
unterstützt damit sie ihr Rechte der
Selbstverteidigung ausüben kann und das
steht ja auch in der un-karte drin und
wir stehen hier ja vor dem Gebäude der
Vereinten Nationen wir unterstützen nur
das auf Selbstverteidigung und der
Ukraine das ist ein Land das brutal
angegriffen wurde durch Russland und
darum geht es in diesem Konflikt
und wir unterstützen die Ukraine aber
gleichzeitig haben wir auch gesagt dass
wir keine Teilnehmer an dem Konflikt
sind und wir wollen natürlich auch keine
Konfrontation mit Russland das ist ja
genau das was er in seiner Rede sagt er
würde vom Westen angegriffen er würde
auf einer 1.000 km langen kontaktlinie
gegen die geballte Militärmaschinerie
des Westens kämpfen die NATO habe sich
gegen ihn verbündet man wolle eine Art
antirussischen Brückenkopf in der
Ukraine erstellen was antworten Sie
ihnen darauf
keine Zweifel worum es hier geht das ist
ein Krieg der von Russland gegen die
Ukraine gestartet wurde die Ukraine hat
international anerkannte Grenzen und
Russland hat die auch anerkannt und
Russland hat diese Grenzen verletzte
zunächst 2014 als die Krim eine kehrt
wurde illegal und dadurch dass die
Separatisten in Don Bass unterstützt
wurden und jetzt im Februar dadurch dass
eine vollständige Invasion der Ukraine
gestartet wurde es gibt keine Zweifel
dass das ein Aggressionskrieg ist und
die alle Nationen weil ein 14 Nationen
in der UN haben diesen Krieg verurteilt
und wir haben das Recht die Ukraine zu
unterstützen um sich selber zu
verteidigen wir müssen verstehen dass
die Ukraine
ist das auch für uns
denn er wird dann lernen dass wenn man
mit Militärgewalt eine Nachbarn
überfällt dann kann er seine eigene
Ziele erreichen und das wird die Zukunft
noch gefährlicher machen also wenn wir
jetzt die Ukraine unterstützen dann ist
das der beste Weg um weitere
Eskalationen bei anderen Ländern in
Europa zu vermeiden
sagt er Generalsekretär der NATO Jens
Stoltenberg ich danke Ihnen für das
Gespräch
dankeschön ich danke Ihnen
das Interview haben wir aus Termin
Gründen aufgezeichnet die NATO-Länder
werden also weiter liefern und die
Ukraine unterstützen Tenor ruhig bleiben
weitermachen keep calm and carry on aber
was bedeutet Putins mobil machen für den
konkreten Verlauf dieses Krieges wie ist
das einzuschätzen wenn der russische
Verteidigungsminister von 300.000
zusätzlichen Soldaten spricht und wie
steht es derzeit um die russische Armee
dazu erstmal ein kurzer Überblick von
Christian von Rechenberg
Putins Armee nach außen der Schein einer
stolzen Streitmacht doch die schönen
Bilder trüben viel modernes Material
funktioniert nicht die Masse stammt noch
aus Zeiten der Sowjetunion wie auch
Teile der Munition die Truppe sei
schlecht motiviert schlecht ausgebildet
schlecht ausgerüstet es gibt
Eliteeinheiten doch die kosten Geld
Putin hat investiert doch von den
Milliarden sei ein Teil angeblich
versickert masse statt Klasse Russlands
Streitkräfte knapp eine Million aktive
Soldaten bestehen zu zwei Drittel aus
Berufs- bzw Zeitsoldaten vertraglich
verpflichtet also und zu einem Drittel
aus Wehrpflichtigen die Zeitsoldaten
können mehr trainieren mehr stehen
länger zur Verfügung doch weil sie teuer
sind hält Russland eben auch an der
Wehrpflicht Fest auch weil man dadurch
den Patriotismus junger Menschen
befeuern will doch noch immer litten sie
unter althergebrachten zum Teil brutalen
Schikanen
schlecht für die Moral und so bleibt
laut Experten diese gewaltige Armee im
Umbruch abhängig von ihren Reservisten
25 Millionen habe das Land angeblich vor
dem ukrainekrieg hatte die Armee knapp
zwei Millionen von ihnen in Bereitschaft
doch die Reserve sei strukturell und
personell in übler Verfassung los zu
kämpfen mögen die wenigsten haben nun
also nochmal 300.000 dazu die neuen
sollen Kampferfahrung haben sagt der
Verteidigungsminister keine Studenten
also keine Rekruten dennoch die
Nachrücker kampfbereit zu machen dauert
Monate gebraucht werden sie jetzt
fraglich also ob sie nicht doch nur
eines sind Kanonenfutter
tja was hat Putin nun von dieser
Mobilisierung darüber möchte ich mit
einem herausragenden Militärexperten auf
der internationalen Bühne sprechen mit
US-General ad Ben Hodges erkämpft den
Afghanistan und Irak und kommandierte
jahrelang die US-Streitkräfte in Europa
guten Abend generell
guten Abend Marietta was glauben Sie
diese Mobilisierung das ist ja zunächst
mal nur eine Ankündigung aber es ist ja
nicht so dass man dann listenabarbeitet
und sagt so bitte morgen früh 8 Uhr beim
wehramt melden und dann geht's ab zur
Front
dass das jetzt zunächst mal ein
strategischer Fehler des kremlins ist
das zu tun dass wir jetzt sehr große
logistische Probleme hervorrufen und es
wird auch eine Peinlichkeit werden ich
glaube nicht dass
allzu viele Leute tatsächlich erscheinen
werden man sieht ja schon
Demonstrationen in den verschiedenen
Städten in Russland und es gab eine
große Schlange von
Autos die versucht über die finnische
Grenze zu kommen das ist sehr unpopulär
und es wird wahrscheinlich auch sehr
schwierig sein den die Auswirkungen
neuer Soldaten an der Front wenigstens
wer wegen während der nächsten zwei drei
Monate zu sehen die müssen erstmal
vorbereitet werden ausgerüstet werden
die müssen dann
verschickt werden und sind ja immer noch
ganz neue Soldaten wenn die erstmal an
die Front kommen also ich sehe da keinen
großen Vorteil für den Kreml durch diese
Teilmobilmachung aber offenkundig
brauchen Sie frische Soldaten schön sie
das Wort frisch das klingt schrecklich
aber wir haben ja auch Begriffe wie
Kanonenfutter die jetzt in diesem
Zusammenhang fallen
ja da haben sie völlig Recht
und die brauchen jetzt mehr Soldaten
russland hat einfach zu wenig Soldaten
gehabt schon von Beginn des von Beginn
an denn die Russen haben sich nicht
wirklich vorbereitet die Dach wir
könnten einfach über die Grenze Rollen
mit ihren Fähigkeiten und
sie haben versucht dieses Problem
oberflächlich zu korrigieren ohne jemals
an die Gründe ihrer Probleme zu gehen an
die Wurzel des Übels und der Mangel an
Kräften an Menschen ist eben ein großes
Problem das wird das werden junge
Menschen sein und
ältere Menschen die schon in der Armee
waren die jetzt einberufen werden sollen
und die kommen in ein Umfeld rein wo sie
bisher verloren haben überall
gab es Tote und Verwundete die
Versorgungslage ist nicht besonders gut
und Internat das ist keine gute
Situation in die man wenig ausgebildete
Soldaten schicken solltest ist kriminell
junge Soldaten in so einer Lage
hineinzubringen und ich denke der
Widerstand oder die Tatsache dass die
Soldaten unglücklich sein werden darüber
wird auch reflektiert werden durch viele
Familien die sich unglücklich fühlen
also teilen Sie die Einschätzung des
deutschen Bundeskanzlers der heute sagte
das was Putin da macht ist dann Akt der
Verzweiflung
ich glaube
das trifft es ganz gut
er ist auf jeden Fall verzweifelt und
versucht jetzt irgendeine Möglichkeit zu
finden um die Dynamik um zu kehren ich
glaube
die Ukraine hat eine unumkehrbare
Dynamik geschaffen und der Kreml
versucht das wieder zu stoppen es gibt
hier keine
rationale militärische Art zu denken das
ist nicht die Arbeit des Generalstabs
das ist die denke der politischen
Führung die irgendwie versucht eine
Lösung zu finden um die Niederlage zu
vermeiden und ehrlich gesagt ich habe
auch schon eher heute mal drüber
nachgedacht das erinnert mich an das was
Hitler am Ende während der letzten Tage
des Dritten Reiches getan hat der hat
einfach die Jungen von der Straße
genommen und alte Männer und ihnen
Uniformen angezogen weil er so
verzweifelt war und
es scheint so als würde Putin die
gleichen Maßnahmen ergreifen wie Adolf
Hitler damals
die Einschätzung von General ben hat
sich danke Ihnen für das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen
auch das Interview haben wir
aufgezeichnet mit Blick auf Putin gibt
es dann natürlich einen gewaltigen
Unterschied der russische Präsident
sitzt nicht in einem Bunker während sein
eigenes Land bombardiert wird die
meisten Russen vor allem im Kernland um
St petersburg und Moskau konnten diesen
Krieg bisher ignorieren das geht jetzt
mit der mobilenmachung so nicht mehr und
prompt gibt es Proteste unser
Korrespondent Christian sem beobachtet
dass er in Moskau Christian es hat viele
Verhaftungen gegeben hört man wie ist es
jetzt am späteren Abend in Moskau
ja wir waren den Abend über hier in der
Moskauer Innenstadt unterwegs sind jetzt
wieder zurück in unserem Moskauer
ZDF-Studio die Lage hat sich beruhigt
aber für den Abend war auch in der
Hauptstadt so Protesten aufgerufen
worden wir sind da hingefahren es war
bis zum Schluss nicht klar wie viele
Menschen da kommen würden weil in den
letzten Wochen gab es ja gar keine
Proteste mehr weil die immer wieder im
Keim erstickt wurden und auch da gab es
ja nur wenn es kleine Anflüge von
Protesten gegen diese Militäroperationen
wie der Konflikt hier genannt wird wenn
die aufkamen wurden die Menschen sofort
verhaftet insofern kamen wir da an waren
dann doch überrascht dass einige
Menschen hunderte würde ich mal sagen
schwer zu schätzen am alten Arbeits
standen das ist eine bekannte
Einkaufsstraße und Touristenstraße hier
in Moskau wir wollten dann natürlich mit
den Teilnehmern sprechen haben ein
Teilnehmer interviewt und der wurde uns
dann vor dem Mikrofon weggerissen von
der Polizei und dann begannen die
Festnahmen dass waren auch gibt noch
keine genauen Zahlen dürften auch
hunderte gewesen sein in Moskau und mir
aufgefallen wir haben den letzten Jahren
ja immer wieder hier Demonstrationen
begleitet ob das für den Kremlkritiker
oder auch zu den umstrittenen
Regionalwahlen hier in Moskau Festnahmen
gab es immer und massives Vorgehen der
Sicherheitskräfte das gab es auch mal
das kennen wir hier in Moskau aber mir
ist heute aufgefallen dass es wirklich
eine gezielte Brutalität gab die
Menschen standen da nur hatten ja auch
gar nichts in der Hand sondern haben nur
gerufen stoppt den Krieg und sie wurden
verhaftet massiv verhaftet und wurden
die Beine weggetreten sie wurden mit
Knüppeln geschlagen es war noch viele
Frauen bei den Protesten dabei auch
viele ältere Frauen die sich dann
zusammengekauert und eingehakt haben und
wirklich geweint haben und auch
schockiert waren über die Gewalt also
Proteste gab es nicht nur in Moskau
sondern auch in vielen anderen Städten
über 1.200 Festnahmen das ist im Moment
das Klima in dem das alles gerade
passiert in Russland Christian danke
schön nach Moskau
der Weimann hier in Deutschland weiter
an der energiefront kämpft sozusagen das
Gasunternehmen Juniper wird weitgehend
verstärkt die gasumlage soll am ersten
Oktober aber trotzdem eingeführt werden
vorerst jedenfalls die Verstaatlichung
von Juniper wird einige Zeit dauern und
so lange gibt es auf jeden Fall erstmal
die gasumlage ja und danach der
Wirtschaftsminister hat da Zweifel und
steht ziemlich unter Beschuss mattes
berichtet
es ist ein Minister unter Druck ein
Minister dem seine Politik gerade
zerbröselt und dessen Antworten
irgendwie genervt wird das Jahr läuft
natürlich nicht wie geplant aber Putin
macht gerade eine general Mobilisierung
und
die Antworten darauf entsprechend wenn
alles mit allem zusammenhängt ist diese
Antwort vielleicht verständlich was aber
die mobilmachungen in Russland und die
Verstaatlichung des wichtigsten
gasimporteurs in Deutschland heute im
konkreten verbindet wird nicht so klar
in der letzten Nacht hatte die
Bundesregierung entschieden den
Gasversorger Juniper zu übernehmen
dessen Abhängigkeit von Russland mache
den Konzern so verwundbar Juniper hat
einen Anteil in ihrem Portfolio von 50%
aus russischem Gas und steht für 40
Prozent der Deutschen Gasversorgung das
zusammengenommen Zwang zum Handeln um
die Versorgungssicherheit für
Deutschland sicherzustellen Robert
Habeck hastet heute im Bundestag von
Ausschuss zur Ausschuss Versuch zu
erklären was die überraschende Übernahme
von Juniper für den Gasmarkt bedeutet
hinter den türenargumentiert er der
Zusammenbruch von Juniper und damit der
Kollaps des Marktes sei nur so zu
verhindern geradezu alternativlos die
Opposition begrüßt die Übernahme
allerdings müsse das jetzt Konsequenzen
haben für die gasumlage ein
Staatskonzern der uniper nun sei dürfe
davon nicht profitieren
die gasumlage ist längst der weiße
Elefant der Ampel alle wissen die ist
vor die Wand gefahren aber keiner in der
Regierung spricht es bisher offen aus
die gasumlage sie spaltet inzwischen
auch die Ampel während der
Finanzminister havix Pläne noch stützt
und keine Rechtsprobleme erkennen kann
entzieht die SPD dem Projekt heute ihr
Vertrauen mit Bedenken sehr ähnlich der
Opposition auch ein Bundesfinanzminister
muss ja ein großes Interesse daran haben
dass eine Einnahmequelle die geschaffen
wird tatsächlich rechtlich hält er kann
kein Interesse daran haben dass wir
monatelange Rechtsstreitigkeiten haben
mit ungewissem Ausgang und insofern
glaube ich dass die Bundesregierung sehr
sorgfältig noch mal beraten sollte ein
Koalitionskrach und Robert Habeck
mittendrin eine spontane aktuelle Stunde
wird zur öffentlichen Schlammschlacht
zwischen Opposition und
Wirtschaftsminister
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger zahlen
gerade tragen eine Umlage bei der wir da
klar ist wer wofür für wen zahlt und ob
sie überhaupt kommt und das ist chaospur
in einer Zeit wo es Sicherheit und
Planbarkeit bräuchte die Gasanlage muss
weg sind wir denn hier im Fußballstadion
oder was ist das mit Demo muss weg sie
sind die muss weg Opposition was ist
denn das für eine Antwort fragen Sie
mich mal dass wir alles nicht gefällt
und das ist mir wünschen würde was alles
weg muss die gasumlage die Belastung der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger Klarheit gibt es
heute wenig morgen geht es für Harbeck
im Parlament wieder um Gas wieder um die
Umlage und wieder um unsere Zukunft
und jetzt Heinz Wolf mit anderen
Nachrichten des Tages
bundesinnenministerin Felser und
bundeskriminalamtspräsident Münch haben
heute das neue BKA Lagebild zur
organisierten Kriminalität vorgelegt
demnach stieg die Zahl der
Ermittlungsverfahren gegen kriminelle
Banden im vergangenen Jahr um rund 17
Prozent auf 696 fast die Hälfte der
Tätergruppen war im Bereich der
Rauschgiftkriminalität aktiv gefolgt von
Wirtschafts- und eigentumskriminalität
der wirtschaftliche Schaden hat sich
mehr als verdoppelt auf 2,2 Milliarden
Euro
die Staatsanwaltschaft in New York hat
Zivilklage erhoben gegen den früheren
US-Präsidenten Trump der Vorwurf Betrug
und Täuschung durch Trumps
Firmenimperium auch drei seiner Kinder
sind beschuldigt die Oberstaatsanwältin
des Bundesstaates New York sprach in
einer Erklärung von irreführenden
Bewertungen der Immobilien Trumps
Absicht sei gewesen die Finanzen je nach
Bedarf kleiner oder größer zu rechnen um
weniger Steuern zu zahlen oder besser an
Kredite zu kommen eine Anwältin Trumps
war auf ihr Amtsmissbrauch vor und
bestritt jegliches Fehlverhalten
in den USA hat die Notenbank am Abend
den Leitzins erneut kräftig angehoben
und die Wachstumsprognose für dieses
Jahr deutlich gesenkt bei der rehhalla
wie reagiert der Finanzmarkt aktuell
darauf ein wenig schockiert nicht so
sehr wegen des kräftigen zinsschritts
damit hatten Anleger ja gerechnet der
Schockmoment kam eher von der Aussage
dass die Fett die Zinsen weiter deutlich
anheben möchte bis Ende des Jahres ja
und dann noch diese kräftig
heruntergeschraubte Wachstumsprognose
und man sieht die erste Reaktion
deutlich ein Kurseinbruch von dem sich
der Dow Jones nur kurz erholen konnte
inzwischen wieder knietief im Minus die
USA Wagen einen weiteren
jumbozinsschritt den dritten in Folge um
0,75 Prozentpunkte auf eine Spanne
zwischen drei bis
3,25%. gleichzeitig senkt die Fett ihre
Prognose auf ein
mini-wirtschaftswachstum von 0,2% dieses
Jahr weltweit gehen den Banken gegen die
hohe Inflation vor auch die Europäische
Zentralbank die ja lange gezögert hatte
dabei kämpfen alle mit demselben Dilemma
reagieren sie zu soft könnte die
Inflation ausufern reagieren sie zu hart
könnten Sie eine Rezession auslösen die
Inflation jedoch so scheint es halten
die meisten Notenbanken inzwischen für
das größere Risiko Valerie Haller vielen
Dank
und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 7 8 24 30 36 48 und die Superzahl
8 weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
zum ersten Mal seit Beginn des
russischen Angriffskrieges auf die
Ukraine sind zwei russische Kosmonauten
und einer amerikanischer Astronaut zur
ISS gestartet mit einer so use
Trägerrakete hob die Crew am Nachmittag
vom russischen weltraumzentrum bei
gründur in Kasachstan ab und dr gut drei
Stunden später erfolgreich an der
internationalen Raumstation an zurzeit
kooperieren Moskau und Washington in der
Raumfahrt noch russland hat jedoch den
Bau einer eigenen Raumstation
angekündigt
vielleicht geht es weiter im
auslandjournal darin unter anderem eine
Reportage über einen jungen Russen der
aus Angst vor Putins mobil machen
geflüchtet ist und Nazan gökte mir
meldet sich dann um 1 Uhr mit unserem
heute-update und wir morgen wieder auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der aktuelle
Tropensturm fiona hat Hurrican Stärke 4
erreicht von möglichen fünf Stufen und
dreht allmählich nach Norden hat hier
Puerto Rico erwischt und auf seinem Weg
nach Norden zieht es nun Richtung
Bermuda mit Stärke 4 also das ist ein
gefährlicher Sturm und wird diese Stärke
weiterhin behalten und sich Richtung
Norden weiter durchsetzen ja wir
behalten das im Auge für die nächsten
Tage schauen wir Richtung Europa und da
haben wir es mit ruhigen Wetter zu tun
vom Wind kaum eine Spur ja und Nebel
gibt es dazu auch etwas warme Luft aus
den aus dem Südwesten in die westlichen
Landesteile schauen wir uns die Nacht an
im Norden gibt es Nebel genauso wie im
Osten sowie an der Donau im Südwesten
klar des größtenteils auf und es wird
teilweise eisig kalt zum Beispiel an den
alpen-
im hessischen Bergland um 0 Grad 10 Grad
Milch ist es an der Nordsee morgen dann
viel Sonnenschein nach Nebelauflösung
vor allem im Südwesten Deutschlands in
der Mitte sind die Wolken mal kompakter
es bleibt größtenteils trocken bei
Temperaturen von 20 Grad am Niederrhein
oder am Oberrhein am kühlsten noch
Richtung Vogtland mit 14 Grad am Freitag
ist es noch einmal trocken und
größtenteils sonnig bei 14 bis 22 Grad
und ab Samstag kommen wieder neue shower
aus dem Südwesten ins Land ein schönen
Abend